one of the things that Sam brought up on
the episode with me was his Infamous
Twitter clip with you what was the
experience of that particular 180
seconds Catching Fire
like you know I felt terrible when that
happened really really terrible
because I've never been on the end of a
Twitter [__] storm to that extent but it
it's not pleasant no matter how
strong-minded you are whatever there's a
reason that Rogan always says don't read
the comments right like like the great
man Joseph Stalin says quantity has a
quality all of its
own so there's only certain number of
negative comments you can ignore until
just the volume of [__] becomes
overwhelming so my primary concern
actually not I don't know Sam well but
uh was for his well-being actually I
just I just worried how he would
experience that more than any anything
that was my concern because our approach
is always about giving a guest an
opportunity to reveal themselves in the
best light possible and for some people
that light shines very brightly and can
burn um but that's not our intention we
never go into an interview with a desire
to out somebody or expose somebody it's
not a got you it's not a got you so I
was worried about him and I emailed him
straight away just to you know check up
on him and and you know also we didn't
put that out we could have done because
we obviously understood that it was a
controversial thing he said and actually
most people don't know this but that was
not the most controversial thing he said
in that interview in my opinion we
talked about Co on locals which was the
payall section of the interview and what
he said there I found quite what did he
say I don't remember the wording and
people have to go and watch it but it
was you know I came away from that
thinking that you know he's
overestimating the threat and as a
result of that he prepared to do some
pretty drastic things or or demand
drastic things to be done um so first
and foremost as somebody who interviews
people for a living I was concerned for
him but I also felt that you know what
he said was wrong I didn't agree with it
um
and I I I my view on it is that if you
overestimate the nature of the threat
all else follows and I think on Trump
and Co that that is where Sam in my
opinion is is well that's why he's doing
what he's doing and saying what he's
saying because if I thought Trump was as
bad as Sam thinks it'd be very tempting
to think along the lines that Sam thinks
along and likewise with Co if I thought
this was like a
bower that
spreads I'd also be you know we should
also be honest you know the conversation
people like well there's never ever ever
any reason for the government to mandate
vaccines and I broadly agree with that
unless the disease is really like
dangerous and deadly I I said this at
the beginning of Co like imagine that
the disease had 100% mortality rate for
all women or it 100% mortality rate for
all people under the age of 10 there'd
be some people who' support it well yeah
but I I think that the the fundamentally
it came down to a risk and reward yeah
equation and most people considered that
the risk of getting coid was not greater
than the risk of either getting the
vaccine or of opening up mandated
vaccines as a pathway overall right and
it's just where do you sit on this
equation there's lots of other things
but broadly I think it's where you sit
on this equation
and Sam I completely agree with him that
I think
CO as an event was like the worst kind
of vaccine that we could have given our
epidemiology our medical system the view
of vaccines overall vaccine skepticism
at Large my bet has gone through the
[__] roof it has it has have you had
a look at this yeah of course it has I
know anecdotally just speaking to people
how much that's that's the case yeah so
if we are to have something that comes
around the next time and it does kill
[__] all children under 10 or all
women or whatever the [__] it's got some
incubation period of 28 days and a
mortality of
40% it's just a scop it's another scop
this is CL Schwab doing it again this is
the WF and it's like oh God like that's
that's literally would have been better
if Co hadn't happened right yeah sure
enough we can get masks out of the way
more quickly and we've got like some
some inefficiency in in the system were
opened up but if you were to look at
coid as a like operational logistical
vaccine our response to it failed us way
worse than if we' never got it at all
and we got a vaccine injury from coid
yes yes we did and and I also think the
one thing that is sort of inexplicably
neglected in all of this is I'd really
like to know where Co came from I'd
really like to know don't you think
that's important don't you think we
should know where it came from because
there are some credible assertions about
its Origins that would suggest that we
may have another pandemic soon um is
that right I haven't seen this well
if this came from a lab in Wuhan because
of gain of function
research and we are not willing to be
honest about that and G of function
research
continues why wouldn't we have another
pandemic I never looked into this much I
know that uh Sam had Matt Ridley and
somebody else somebody else on his show
we've had Matt on to talk about this as
well yeah and the truth is we don't know
yeah uh but I I'm using the kind of the
smell test here because I grew up in a
in a in a communist
Society um and what communist societies
do when there is something and all
societies do this to a large extent
because people don't like to to expose
their their own flaws and no one wants
to be like oh I was responsible for
killing millions of people you know but
they will cover it up in a way that you
know that is proper and Matt actually
gave this example of there was a leak
somewhere in the Soviet Union which was
a radioactive leak I think or maybe it
was a biological uh and they covered up
for ages and then you know when the
Soviet Union collapsed we finally find
out no no it was actually a leak so if
this is a product of uh gain of function
research getting out into the real world
which is credible that there's there's
very credible assertions about that the
world needs to know and this type of
research needs to
end but if we are unwilling to have that
conversation honestly and do the proper
investigations which would be difficult
because the CCP wouldn't want that and
on top of that you've got all this other
[__] about how it's racist and all
of that uh we've got a problem so the I
I think my worry with everything that's
happened with Co is not only have we not
learned the lessons I feel like like you
said we've got a vaccine injury from the
experience and everyone is sort of stuck
in their corner and like Sam said to you
everyone's got their own facts about it
now correct yeah
um that's a
problem it's interesting what you said
about the felt sense of being in the
blast radius of Sam's online experience
I noticed it if someone called it Sam
his world embarrassment tour because he
did my show he did Steven's show and he
did Tom bil's
Show and I don't know man like there
seems to be
something it's almost like there was
resentment sat on the internet latent
resentment sat on the internet waiting
for Sam to [__] up and then he did a
thing oh maybe maybe it's right I don't
think it was personal that was my the
reason I paused there I don't think it
was personal to Sam I think particularly
on his Trump comments there are a lot of
people who were like like this is what
we always knew the Trump haters think
deep inside and Sam was willing to
vocalize it which is I don't care how
big the transgressions are on the other
side I don't care what Hunter Biden has
done I don't care what Joe Biden's done
no matter what they do it can never be
as bad as orange man bad and that's sort
of how he came across and so the people
who who fell gastl this entire time
about um you know the overestimation of
the threat of trump they they were
Vindicated in that moment and I think
Sam just caught him was caught in the
Rage of people feeling like the kind of
like the perfect timed storm with the
perfect Pebble in the perfect river that
directed it yeah yeah yeah yeah it's so
interesting man you know we I had this
conversation with a a fitness influencer
called Sarah Safari in La a couple of
weeks ago uh I'd be interested to get
your thoughts on this I think it's
analogous to the Sam situation a lot of
of people especially right of Center say
things like you can't judge somebody on
just one thing that they
say yet when it came to a six-pack of
Bud Light being sent to Dylan mvan by
some marketing intern somewhere deep in
the annals of the Anisa Bush thing or
millerite release one video the
millerite thing felt a little bit more
produced it's probably gone through a
few more layers but largely I just
wondered I thought it was interesting
that
the charity that a lot of people right
of Center ask to be given to their
commentators or you know their Champions
that are cancelled for taking out of
context points there was that uh rosan
bar bit with theovon where she made a
joke about the Jews which was the most
egregious clipping that I've ever seen
from anything ever the end of a three
minute long bit and they took the final
30 seconds and put it up as if it was
representative of the whole thing it was
so [__]
bad but I did notice nobody decided to
use that same idea about well hang on a
second maybe maybe this is just one
small Department in one small corner of
one small brand marketing push and they
gave this person who is very unpopular
on the internet a six-pack of Bud Light
and before you know it Kid Rock's got an
AR-15 pointed at a few cases of your
drink what do you think about so I think
I would uh separate those two out so Sam
I think is that point applies very much
and this is what the angle I'm coming up
from I felt that while I strongly
disagree with what he said I think that
was clear in the interview um he has
enough credit in the bank with me that
I'm willing to have a lot of
understanding and a lot of Grace with
him and I I like and what I would say as
well is you know we were having a lot of
tech issues on the day that we
interviewed Sam and he sat there for
like a good hour while we were trying to
scrambling to get the microphones to
work and he was the most decent human
being that we've had on the show you see
who someone really is when the cameras
aren't rolling that seemed to me like a
really important thing that other people
obviously wouldn't have seen so um I
have a lot of time for Sam and respect
for him I don't have the same
relationship with d
malany and I also think you haven't
taken a world of wisdom from Dyan milany
over the last you'll be surprised man
you'll be surprised and so um I think
look Dylan mlan is a symbol in to many
people like Sam is a symbol to many
people for different things but I I
think it's a slightly different issue
because you I don't know if you saw but
immediately after the the dill mulany
controversy the marketing executive who
was responsible for this there was there
was a video of her talking to I think a
reporter about the thinking
behind
what the idea there was it seemed a
little bit more thought out it was
thought out and her her angle was our
our customers are [__] that was her
angle our [__] yeah what's a [__]
customer well it was just uh it's just
these guys who've got like a you know
old-fashioned sense of humor and they
don't do you know what I mean like we're
going to educate our customers and I'm
like you sell beer that's not your job
sell them the [__] beer and shut up
right um and look the trans issue for
reasons I actually think are quite
understandable and obvious is the
lightning rod of our time um so I'm not
surprised that that caused the reaction
that it did and and I understand it I I
I do think and I said I wrote a substack
on this at the time um that perhaps the
giving so much attention to it is what
prompts these Brands to to go down this
route obviously with Dyan malania
backfired for sure it's a role of the
dice for attention it's a role of the
dice for attention that I don't think
they considered and I think that
executive ended up being fired I do
understand why people got as fired up
about as they did because your rewarding
behavior that a lot of people would feel
is the wrong Behavior to reward in the
public eye Dylan milany but that woman
is one lady maybe maybe in her interview
with the reporter she said this went all
the way up and the director CE the
[__] Chief marketing officer or
whatever was involved in this but if it
wasn't the
case I don't think if if it turned out
that it was one small group in in the
Corner as I like guessed or whatever I
don't think that the internet would have
given budlight any more leeway I don't
think they would have said we need to
separate the art and the artist here you
know they've made beer for three decades
for however [__] long it's been
around and maybe maybe it's righty maybe
it it shows their woke bonafides it
shows that they're the man hating like
left leaning bluee head CS that they
always
were but I don't know like it seems like
a lot of the time people want it's a
it's a smart idea to be able to say
Rogan has been in a few controversies
over the last few years most people said
I have faith that you're telling me this
is the tip of the
iceberg I've seen the whole Iceberg
right I know that there is nothing
lurking deep down in the depths massive
Advantage he has is he's published like
5,000 hours of content over the last
decade which means that you have a
pretty good
body of evidence that sits on the other
side of the scale but light you don't
know much about what's going on inside
of the marketing department but I just
thought it was interesting I thought
that maybe this is a time where it would
be illustrative and you should be
careful about trans transgressing rules
that you want to be enforced so if you
want the don't judge somebody by one
single occurrence rule to be enforced
and then you don't enforce
it that as you said before that's tiit
for Tat game it opens up well they did
it so this is playground mentality I
understand what you mean but I think I
disagree actually I think the reason
that people uh were as upset about as
they are is while it's these are
different companies the sense is imagine
it wasn't just Rogan who said something
but it was Chris Williamson and
trigonometry and all the other
podcasters who do what we do all at one
point said the same thing and then there
was yet another example of a podcast
saying so when you look at the
Gillette M toxic mascul ad if you look
at all the other instances where
corporations put Pride flags all they
replace their brand with in the Middle
East not well obviously not yeah do they
do it in Russia they can't do it in
Russia I doubt it I doubt it I can't
imagine why in Mother Russia gay has you
yeah exactly so I think what people felt
was here again we've got a corporation
just absolutely taking the piss
lecturing the ordinary public and
thrusting these very Niche issues onto
what is a very very very like normal
household beer and you just can't escape
this [__] that's what I think people
feel kind of a straw that broke the
camels back big Corporation overall
that's interesting because what I was
doing was I was taking budlight as a
individual instance on its own what
you're saying is this is more endemic of
a broader Trend among big corporations
well broadly speaking if you think about
what the anti-woke narrative is the
anti-woke narrative is and I agree with
very large part of it is that most of
the major institutions whether that be
media whether that be the Civil Service
whether that be the political systems
the parties the uh the corporations the
education system they've all been
captured or corrupted uh or through some
other mechanism become uh the projectors
of a certain worldview onto the public
who do not share that world view and so
when you
see the toxic masculinity Gillette ad
which is like hey you know you you're a
man you're a piece of [__] buy a
razor you know hey you're a piece of
[__] buy our beer Etc it sort of builds
up to a point like why is everyone
telling me I'm a piece of [__] um and it
gets old and you know and I actually you
know particularly this anti mascul anti-
masculinity narrative that you see
everywhere in movies uh in advertising
in in all sorts of different genres uh I
think it's really really dangerous
because if you think about Gillette ads
in the '90s you were a bit younger than
me I don't know if you remember them but
they were the best a man can get and
it's like some blonde hot chicken like a
whatever she's like actually that wasn't
the '90s Gillette ads the '90s Gillette
ads were a bunch of men being healthy
masculinity he was a man putting his tie
on as he holds his baby up before he's
going to work he was a man uh hugging
his son on his way to his wedding he was
a man protecting his wife or you know it
was a it was a healthy view of men and
relationships and men and women and so
on um and I I sort of say you know
healthy masculinity is the '90s Gillette
ads that's what it looks like um men
being responsible men in relationships
with women being respectful being kind
but also being strong looking after
their children teaching younger versions
of men had to be men Etc right um and I
understand why people men and women are
[__] tired really really tired of
this idea that men are bad and evil and
my wife who's complet I always say my
wife is completely apolitical and as a
result of that extremely
based right like she hates this [__] and
I can't tell you how many women I speak
to who are very very tired of men being
demonized in this way and so am I well
especially given that a lot of those
women will have sons and they want their
partner to be good and healthy they
don't want them to be feeble you know um
so I actually I understand the pushback
against that I really do and I think
it's necessary this episode is brought
to you by short form short form is my
absolute favorite way to discover new
non-fiction books and gain deeper
insights into books that I've already
read you guys know about how important
my reading list is to me and short form
is an easier faster and cheaper way to
dive into ideas that I've always been
curious about they're essentially book
summaries on steroids provide super
detailed Guides of the book's key ideas
and they've got smart insights and
interactive exercises I really love
using short form to revisit some of my
alltime favorite books like the 48 Laws
of Power by Robert Green they've got
onepage summaries and breakdowns of each
chapter that will help you to better
absorb and solidify all of the learnings
without having to go back through a book
that you've already read the best part
is that they always keep their Library
fresh short form drops new book guides
and articles every week and subscribers
get to vote on what books to cover you
can try short form completely free for 5
days with no obligation by following the
link in the description or by going to
short.com slod wisdom and you'll get an
additional 20% off if you sign up for
the annual subscription that's short.com
slod wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip then
press here for the fulllength 2our plus
podcast with
Constantin